the protagonist of the movie is an obese
old-fashioned and carefree man named
Dusty all he cares about is eating and
watching vintage movies with the
advancements in technology the world has
moved on but Dusty is still stuck in the
80s he doesn't like using smartphones
thinks texting is a waste of time and
even believes that emojis are strange
come on Dusty even the grapefruit the
one thing he fears is Millennials he
can't stand teenagers who have
contrasting opinions to his at the start
of the movie Dusty is in the car
munching on a burger and listening to
some 80s rock despite being 50 years old
he is Carefree and doesn't have a
full-time job this habit has caused
Dusty to lose all his friends but he
could care less about it soon a bunch of
Millennials catch him in the act and
take videos of him Dusty is obviously
uncomfortable but due to his super
awkward nature he can't say a word to
them after a while his niece Chloe joins
him in his car and the two proceed to a
movie theater it turns out that they
have been watching movies together since
Chloe was young and this tradition is
being continued today the two appear to
be close but with the contrasting
differences in age and habits it's clear
that Chloe is a bit weirded out by her
uncle this becomes even more evident
when Dusty plays an old song which she
calls boring get out of the car Chloe on
reaching a theater called cinethrax the
uncle niece Duo starts debating on what
movie to watch Dusty wants to go with a
vintage 80s movie which he has already
seen 10 times but Chloe wants to watch a
cinethrax exclusive 3D movie called
Chosen and eventually the stubborn niece
gets her way they then head to the
ticket line where a lot of Millennials
are clicking selfies and texting as
expected Uncle Dusty is disgusted by the
sight and to make matters worse he
doesn't even have the money to purchase
the movie tickets because they are that
expensive this is part of modern living
that Uncle Dusty can't run away from
hence Chloe reluctantly coughs up some
cash strangely all the cinethrax
employees including the ticket seller
and the bouncers have a weird and gloomy
look on their faces sounds normal to me
before entering the main theater Uncle
Dusty checks his 3D glasses into the bin
and brings out his own bulky glasses
which he calls Schiff apparently he
hates 3D movies so much that he has
brought these shifters to Flatline them
into normal 2D movies he has even
brought a pair for his niece Chloe but
as expected the latter doesn't want to
wear them after this Dusty heads to the
canteen to buy some popcorn there some
Millennials gang up on him and inquire
if he has accidentally ended up in the
3D section Dusty simply says that he is
a movie Freak and leaves weird flex but
okay when he enters the main theater he
finds the manager of sinisterax a good
looking guy named Zach flirting with
Chloe however as soon as Dusty
approaches them Zach makes an excuse and
leaves however at the same time two of
Chloe's friends arrive and sit next to
her it turns out this was her plan all
along the movie time with her uncle was
just an excuse to get out of the house
Dusty is annoyed that Chloe's not
spending time with him and also because
her friends have taken his seat he tries
convincing her to sit with him but Chloe
doesn't want to she has started seeing
her uncle as a boring person who will
embarrass her in front of her friends
every chance he gets hearing this Dusty
becomes sad but still he decides to sit
right behind Chloe's seat soon Zach gets
on stage and announces that the movie is
about to begin he lays out the roles
that no one is allowed to use their
phones and that everyone has to put
their cinethrax 3D glasses on the
Millennials are pumped up with the
announcement and they start cheering in
excitement then the movie chosen finally
begins it is a love story with some
pretty weird acting and story lines but
nonetheless because of the ultra
realistic 3D action the Millennials are
loving it they scream and cheer at
literally every bit of dialogue however
Uncle Dusty who is not wearing any
glasses is left disappointed with the
movie he can't wait to go home already
shortly after he remembers his shifter
glasses and decides to put them on
however because they Flatline the 3D
into a boring 2D version Dusty is still
not intrigued so he decides to annoy the
other people around he sees one of
Chloe's friends texting and reminds her
that using the phone is not allowed in
the theater in fact he causes a minor
Ruckus which doesn't sit well with the
other Millennials there at last when
Dusty still refuses to back down Chloe
tells her friend to stop stop using the
phone so that they can watch the movie
in peace Dusty believes that he is one
completely oblivious that he's
embarrassing his niece in front of her
cool friends as the movie goes on Dusty
gets more and more bored in one scene he
notices something very unusual as if the
screen is faulty however when he takes
off his shifter glasses there is nothing
confused Dusty wants to try on the
cinethrax glasses to see what the real
movie experience is like he asks Chloe
to lender his glasses for a while but by
this time she is fed up with her uncle's
childish Antics she bluntly berates him
for embarrassing her in front of her
friends and requests him to act normally
left with no options Uncle Dusty puts on
his shifter glasses and continues
watching the movie suddenly he notices a
giant worm-like creature peering through
the screen all the Millennials in the
theater are completely oblivious to the
worm's presence but Dusty can see it
clearly terrified he quickly takes off
his glasses and with this the worm
disappears a few minutes pass by but the
worm is nowhere to be seen so dusty
suspects that it has something to do
with his 2D glass hence he puts them
back on and as soon as he does the giant
worm attacks him with its suckers Dusty
screams and horror and Causes Chaos
inside the theater he also drops his
popcorn all over Chloe and her friends
enraged the Millennials start calling
him names but Dusty is sure that there
is something unusual going on inside the
theater he tries explaining it to Chloe
but as expected she is having none of it
instead she is embarrassed and expresses
her regrets about him being there the
commotion soon attracts the cinethrax
manager Zach who approaches Dusty and
takes him away much to the Delight of
the other Millennials yeah
old people suck worried that her uncle
has gotten himself into trouble Chloe
also follows outside Dusty tries to
explain that something came out of the
screen and approached him but Zach
concludes that the old man is simply
mistaking the ultra realistic 3D action
for a real thing however Dusty is sure
that he saw a worm-like creature at last
he decides to get a refund and leave the
place but to his surprise Chloe doesn't
want to go instead she chastises her
uncle for embarrassing her several times
just so that he can become the center of
Attraction saying this she leaves him
and goes back inside the theater Dusty
tries going after her but Zack stops him
saying he's not allowed to go in there
anymore left with no choice a devastated
Uncle Dusty decides to wait for Chloe
till the movie ends but since he cannot
wait in the main hall Zack takes him to
the projection room there Zack and his
employees start talking about how
cinethrax will take over the world
because of its super realistic
cinematics and visuals the age of old 2D
movies is gone and now 3D has taken over
James Cameron is that you they also ask
Dusty to give it a try and if he still
doesn't like it they will refund his
money Zack then hands Dusty a pair of
synithrax glasses but after a long
thought the latter rejects it because of
this the synithrax employees become
enraged and suddenly turn into possessed
zombie-like beings they then attack
Dusty and almost succeed in driving him
into a sharp object but somehow the
uncle manages to escape from their
clutches how did he do it he simply took
a rotten Burger out of his pocket and
shoved it into the possessed zombies
Dusty then runs to the main hall and
tries finding a way out of the building
however it is impossible as all the
synotherax employees have turned into
zombies and are on the lookout for him
so dusty sneaks inside the storm room
and braces himself to do the one thing
which he hates the most texting he sends
several messages to Chloe where he
apologizes for being a jerk and also
admits that he is scared of losing her
then he proceeds to Warner of the
impending danger but before he can do so
Zach and the others breaking through the
door and take him away meanwhile Chloe
has started feeling bad for scolding her
uncle earlier she waits for his next
message but it doesn't come hence when
she finds his shifter glasses lying on
the floor she picks them up and tries
them on lo and behold she notices a
giant tentacled creature which has now
taken over the entire screen the
creature is also sucking the life out of
all the other Millennials meaning that
Chloe is the only uninfected human left
in the theater terrified she takes off
her glasses and tries running but all
the infected Millennials start following
her a major struggle ensues and it
appears as if all hope is low lost but
fortunately with the help of a prop
sword Chloe manages to swat the hundreds
of infected Millennials before entering
the projection room there she notices
her uncle banned and tied to a chair and
finally realizes that he was telling the
truth either that or he's into some
kinky stuff however before she could
help him Zach and the others arrive and
apprehend her following this Zack
reveals the main creature behind all
this Mayhem it turns out to be an alien
which has traveled from another galaxy
to extend its species Zach mentions that
being infected was the best thing to
ever happen to him as now he doesn't
feel any pain or anxiety he also
encourages the uncle niece Duo to
embrace the change as the alien only
wants to help them overcome their
miserable and boring lives saying this
he forcefully puts on a pair of
sinethrax 3D glasses to Dusty and makes
him watch the movie This Will apparently
turn him into one of them but
fortunately Chloe intervenes in the nick
of time and stabs the alien with a
broken piece of glass this momentarily
stuns the infected zombies allowing
Chloe to untie her uncle from bondage
unfortunately because they are about to
escape Zach releases a tentacle from his
mouth which grabs Chloe and starts
possessing her and in no time her face
starts turning implying that the alien
has entered her body just then Uncle
Dusty grabs an ax and chops off Zach's
head like an 80s hero but by this time
the damage has already been done soon
the two reached the exitor and when
Dusty opens it he sees that the city
outside has been ravaged by a colossal
alien here he finally realizes that the
world has been taken over by aliens at
the same time Chloe also changes her
demeanor she tells her uncle to embrace
the change and accept the fact that
there is no escaping she then mentions
that Zach was right there is no pain or
anxiety in this life soon the other
Millennials and synithrax employees also
arrive and start persuading him to
accept the change they even sing a song
to help Dusty change his mind I'll take
you to the candy shop at last realizing
that there is no hope Dusty finally
gives in and starts singing along to the
song I'll let you lick the lollipop in
the last scene all the people get back
inside the theater where the same movie
is being played Chloe who is now
completely possessed gives her uncle a
pair of the cinethrax glasses so that he
can embrace the change and become one of
them the movie ends as Dusty anxiously
waits for the alien to arrive and
possess him
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching